when i think of you as well
like i mean i'll never forget that night
at the lab factory but
if there's one thing that you stand out
in my mind it's that you
love birthdays more than like maybe even
more than my fiance
and she [ __ ] loves birthdays but you
make a big deal out of it every single
year
wow i guess i'm not i'm not religious so
i don't have any holidays except my own
uh birth which i guess is narcissistic
but
i just like going out for my birthday i
used to
have this little [ __ ] i used to live
in this little [ __ ] shoebox
apartment
in hollywood on santa monica
and wilcox like kind of by vine santa
monica and vine by the army and navy
store
and it was total rat's nest and um
i used to when i first first few years
of the eric andre show i was actually
making money and because i was like
scraping by for you know the first
many years when i lived here but then i
started making money but i still lived
in the [ __ ] shoebox
so i was saving up my money but my
birthday i would splurge
and get a bunch of camels and zebras and
exotic animals
and cram them into the driveway of my
apartment building
and then we would get like illegal
fireworks and i would like we would like
huff
ether those are the best ones because i
was like
cramming my apartment full of people
like a clown car
and doing all these exotic drugs and
parting with animals we had a stripper
that had a house arrest anklet
uh on one year those were like
that was the glory day of the party as
the party expanded it kind of just
became like a fun
regular party but there's nothing
regular about your birthday party every
year it's a different thing
every year it's a different theme i
still have in my closet one of these
wigs you have like
these these uh fancy wigs for everybody
from from one of your birthday parties i
went to
but you just said about getting exotic
animals did people yell at you for
having exotic animals at your birthday
party
no the the don't let my fiance hear that
she'll get very upset with you
the neighbors were so like
supportive the camel would walk around
like the zebra and you got to like hold
the
girls would love it because they got to
pet the baby goats and pet the little
bunnies and
like it was like a petting zoo you know
so i mean what's your budget
on on your birthday when i was doing
those they were probably like
i was probably dropping like five grand
on like
animals and and and i would get like
clowns and stilt walkers and jugglers
and
fire breathers and we had and he lived
in a small apartment
very small apartment that was like the
comedy of it like how much [ __ ] and
chaos can we cram in
i had a dj set up on top of my stove and
he accidentally turned the stove on and
his equipment caught on fire
and then my my neighbor next door
started was pissed and started throwing
glass bottles at people at the party
my second a.d came in and ate like an
entire plate of weed brownies thinking
they were regular brownies and
i had like a really bad time but also
the gate broke open and just like
drifters from the neighborhood started
coming into my house those were
those are the days i miss those days
yeah dude i got a question for you steve
at what point in your life at what age
did you stop
to start hating birthdays like because
at 23 24 it's a party
and then 25 26 like i i can tell you
exactly when
okay my 26th birthday
i was working in the circus as a circus
clown
i showed up that day i did not tell a
single
[ __ ] person in the circus that it was
my birthday
i uh i i was i was uh i just felt like
it's not cool anymore man not not 26
too old but what'd you do for your 25th
birthday too old to be psyched
uh my 25th birthday i was at the time of
your life
i was performing in a in a nightclub
like getting drunk and breathing fire
and clown makeup and
uh i blacked out and blacked out
completely
uh but yeah i just think birthdays make
me older and
and got it you look for the amount of
drugs and booze and toxins you put in
your body you look
incredibly handsome and you are aging
gracefully i mean you don't look you
look exactly
like you have for the past 20 years i
don't i do not get it i have like
three cocktails and i just age
like eric stoltz in that movie mask
is that rocky dennis yeah rocky dennis
i'm like running
dennis
thank you so much for watching this clip
and guess what
i have the number 30 ranked hot sauce on
all of amazon
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on amazon and
type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole and
order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon
and buy stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
yeah yeah
dude